oh okay cool
oh uh let's go let's go let's go uh
voldemort under my hat scarf i i i had
some some ideas
wanna talk about it nah it what it
we're sorry it didn't work out um it it
it uh that isn't even in it we met once
i don't know him what it right the only
it that exists is the it in my head
the made up stupid fantasy it that only
exists
in my silly little girl head right
how does it become so big so fast what
kind of nobody lets that happen
this girl you're looking at her
you're not a nobody come on you knew
right you knew
she's a thirsty nobody that will jump if
you dangle any passable mail in front of
her you knew
that i couldn't resist a son when you
offered him up that is my problem i
i i lose my mind over every bashir with
a
good beard that smiles at me you know
sorry bashir with a good beard
that's brilliant what
why won't you love me why won't you text
me back
leave me on red ghost me like i'm dead
are my clothes too tight do i laugh
too much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] you very much
[Music]
something momentous happened that day i
with lady parts had penned a punk anthem
shown from the fabric of my life
i had never written a song before
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was sick what did i tell you oh my
gosh what did i tell you
that was sick man it was all right
[Music]
you